colorino globine ces genres l'ancêtre de
tous les films gore qui se passe en colo
la mère de max joue nancy une fille tout
coincé je lis genre à quelle heure ouvre
la boutique c'est chouette d'honorer sa
mémoire comme ça c'est l'anniversaire de
sa mort ce soir
au moins je vais les revoir même si elle
est pourchassé par un dingue avec une
machette
c'est quoi ce bruit salut salut c'est là
que le blouf insu donc on est dans le
film quoi salut c'est quoi ton max
quelqu'un va cueillir des fraises avec
moi non mais je veux bien m'occuper de
thé melon je parle de ces petites niches
d'amour dialogues sont web montrant
poulies vous avez entendu s'ils y
arrivent tous ceux qui couchent dans ce
film si pointu génial soit h
on me l'a donné à petit ses films et
comment on en sort ce genre de film se
termine quand la dernière fille qui
reste arrive enfin à tuer lui ses polars
c'est elle la dernière fille on n'a qu'à
rester avec elle jusqu'à la fin du film
tout ce que je veux savoir c'est qu'on
lioran je leur ai dit tu payes
tronçonneuses des [__] couteau et
j'avais eu ma clan
vite qu'est-ce qui se passe
je vois plus les couleurs je fais un
appart y sont nés dans un flashback
je me demande si le sens et du colorant
gens si les personnages du film ou du
sirop de maïs dans les best seller
change confiant je sais que tu es censé
mourir dans le film mais ça veut pas
dire que c'est obligatoire va se battre
ce qui se passe
le film est haut
papa